go to matt finn who's on the ground
outside in minneapolis matt
hey guys this is becoming an escalating
scene here outside of the rally a short
while ago we saw people lighting
maga hats on fire lighting other things
on fire people
rushing police throwing objects at
police calling them pigs
and happening here right now there's a
confrontation of
reporters lined up against police it's
kind of settled down now but
uh for a while there this was a pretty
intense scene
here comes something that was just
thrown out i don't know a cup or
something at police officers but
you know the scene all night long has
been intensifying people
have been in our faces there have been
instigators there have been a few
characters
who sought to uh to disrupt and suppress
media crews here tonight
and uh it seems like right now this is
uh coming to a point where hopefully
things will
eventually settle we'll continue to
monitor this and update you throughout
the night
but matt matt i got a question for you
if you can hear me what's going to
happen when you got 20
000 trump supporters exit those
buildings
wearing those maga hats
what is that question what is going to
happen when the
20 000 people that are trump supporters
exit that building that's what we've
kind of been bracing for
i guess it's anyone's guess there are
police here in riot gear
there are police close nearby around the
block there is certainly a very large
police presence we see buses
we see all types of vehicles and there
i've
i mean you might be able to see some on
camera but there are some bad actors in
this crowd tonight we have experienced
them
they have been vulgar they have been
jumping in front of our cameras cursing
at us
which is typical for any protest i have
personally covered
crowds and protests outside of donald
trump rallies across this country
and tonight i would say is right up
there with a crowd that has some of the
worst instigators and
uh you know we witnessed some type of
what might have been tear gas
earlier there's something else that was
just thrown at a police officer on a
horse
these people are calling officers pigs
so unfortunately there are some people
here some protesters
who are exercising their freedom of
speech and right to protest but also
instigating matt how many people are we
talking about in this uh
this riotous type of atmosphere that
you're in how many people are protesting
i hate to use numbers on air because
then we get criticized for
you know giving the wrong estimate but i
would say you know we see at least
hundreds of people here right now and
early in the night there were
at least 1 000 protesters here and that
might be a low estimate
so again as people are now the rally is
wrapped up do you see
any of those people in the arena
actually coming out and getting close to
what we're seeing on camera
so what you're seeing on camera is uh
this line between police and
demonstrators and
because the protesters kind of rushed
police they actually rushed in the
opposite direction of the arena these
these protesters now are facing away
from the arena so
uh i can't tell from my vantage point
but perhaps the the president trump
supporters are
exiting the arena without running into
these people
right now and when they started to come
into the arena were the protesters
though allowed to get in close proximity
to those people
or were they separated into a different
area
uh so we've been out here all day and
you know as we see with trump rallies
across the country
thousands and uh there's another object
just throwing it the horse
uh you know the horse are obviously
reacting to this but
to answer your question uh you know
we're out here all day thousands and
thousands of people lined up
but they uh they were separated from the
protesters and the majority of the
protesters you're seeing here right now
did not arrive until later in the
evening so the majority of the president
trump supporters lining up to get inside
of the rally
did not face these protesters on the way
in but it seems like there are certainly
going to be some that are going to have
to face them
on the way out we see a number of people
with signs and when they're yelling and
screaming things can you give us a sense
of
what is their message
we're hearing some of the signature
chants who streets our streets
shut it down um you know i can't confirm
but our crew and our security identified
what are probably members of antifa
uh they have met you know they have the
handkerchiefs covering their mouths we
had to relocate several times throughout
the night
uh we're we are okay but there were
several times when instigators were
going to clearly interfere
with our reports and that's what they
wanted to do and and that's their
message that they come here to shut it
down and
that's what they're doing we saw one
maybe two fires just
moments ago what very much appeared to
be maga hats on fire we saw people
cursing police
rushing at them throwing all types of
objects at them and we're still
witnessing that right now people are
throwing bottles at police on horses
the horses are reacting they're backing
up there were a couple moments just a
short while ago that were very intense
this now is
a much more calm scene but there are
still a lot of people out here
and there are still a lot of police
pushing back matt thank you for that
report
and stay safe